bonjour à toutes et à tous donc je vais
essayer de vous faire un zoom date
d'aujourd'hui puisque les choses a calé
évolue d'heure en heure donc ce qui est
vrai à l'heure actuelle ne peut plus
l'être éventuellement dans deux heures
vous savez qu'en 2003 lionel non 99
qu'il ya de ce pain a ouvert un centre
qu'on a appelé le centre de sangatte
pour accueillir en fait les population
kosovare
donc notre aventure a démarré cette
année là et en 2003
c'est au nicolas sarkozy à l'appel des
élus de toutes sensibilités qui est venu
fermer ce centre
et il a bien fait depuis les choses ont
changé ont évolué puisque on a deux ou
trois ans en fait d' avance sur ce qu'il
se passe au niveau européen et
international et donc on détecte
beaucoup plus facilement quelles sont
les conséquences des problèmes que nous
vivons aujourd'hui il ya maintenant plus
d'un an j'ai alerté le ministre de
l'intérieur les différents gouvernements
le conseil de l'europe puisque on voyait
le flux des migrants arrivés en masse a
calé et aujourd'hui on se retrouve avec
les hier 3500 je pense qu'aujourd'hui on
est plus près des 4000 que des 3500 d'il
ya quinze jours
ce phénomène est encore plus particulier
puisque vous savez que les migrants qui
se trouvent à kehl et ne demandent pas
l'asile et donc ils sont moins 10% à
demander l'asile en france et de ce fait
ils ne sont pas calculés et ils ne sont
pas traités donc on se retrouve en
permanence avec une population que l'on
ne gère pas que la collectivité a essayé
de façon humanitaire à mettre en place
quelques dispositifs parce qu'il valait
mieux les voir dans certains endroits
plutôt que dispersé dans l'ensemble de
la ville à travers des squats qui avait
une jauge de 200 à 800 migrants et donc
qui crée en permanence eu des problèmes
avec la population
donc il y a un an toujours j'ai donc
demandé au ministre de l'intérieur d'
accepter de mettre en place un centre
d'accueil de jour pas puis par humanité
mais aussi parce qu' il fallait bien que
j'ai une réponse face à vos occupations
puisque les pouvoirs publics sont
défaillants dans le domaine et que c'est
un message très fort que mes collègues
ont bien entendu et vont bien relayé
c'est celui de dire qu'on ne peut pas
faire de l'humanité si on ne fait pas de
la fermeté et que l'un ne peut pas aller
sans l'autre
à partir de là on a posé vraiment les
fondamentaux s'aperçoit qu'en france on
a vraiment une problématique une
problématique au niveau tout simplement
de l'application des lois de la
république et donc déjà si on pouvait
faire du lobbying met la pression pour
que ces lois de la république puisse
être appliquée et bien il y aurait déjà
beaucoup moins de difficultés puisque
nous dans notre territoire nous avons
des personnes qui y sont enregistrés
suivront texte mais et il y en a un
certain nombre c'est une majorité qui ne
le sont pas qui ne sont ni enregistré ni
calculer puisque sur la base du
déclaratif et bien on enregistre rien
c'est quand même inquiétant parce que ça
veut dire qu'on ne peut pas prendre en
compte cette population ne sait même pas
comment l'accompagner
on ne sait même pas où il faut la
reconduire comment dans quelles
conditions
donc on havre est une vraie
problématique et et dans les mesures qui
seront annoncées j'espère en tous les
cas que une de ces mesures sur à forte
dans ce sens parce que ça crée un
franchement un vrai problème de gestion
à calais mais ça ça risque et ça devrait
en tous les cas le poser dans les
collectivités qui accueille alors 7,7
populations continuent à arriver il faut
savoir que dans ces populations qui
arrive il y a bien sûr les réfugiés les
migrants des fois on sait plus trop
quelle qu'elle profite en fait se trouve
derrière ces mots ou un statut est en
fait ces personnes arrivent entouré est
noyautée par des organisations par des
passeurs très clairement et là on a
également au niveau des lois de la
république une défaillance puisque les
systèmes ne sont pas suffisamment
organisés et on voit très bien que au
delà de la volonté la volonté politique
n'est pas là donc il faut vraiment
insisté dans ce domaine si pour certains
responsables donc et spécialistes qui
sont venus à calais ils voient bien que
en se promenant en fait dans la lande ce
lieu qui devait être simplement une zone
un pôle d'attentes sécurisé pour
permettre justement d'identifier quels
étaient ces personnes et d éloigner de
l'épaisseur et bien on
voit on arrive on a les guetteurs on a
là toute l'organisation nous en tous les
cas on la voit et donc on voit bien que
des forces de l'ordre dans tous les cas
sont défaillantes et non pas en fait les
consignes et c'est ça qui est encore
plus grave
non pas les consignes pour intervenir
donc dans tout tout ce dispositif
c'est vrai que moi je suis un maire qui
doit et alliés l'humanité parce que 3500
migrants dans un territoire
ça demande aussi derrière une obligation
d'hygiène de sécurité et donc
d'insalubrité pour le bien des migrants
mais aussi pour le bien de sa population
il faut le savoir et surtout et ensuite
il faut d'un autre côté se battre au
quotidien pour que le ministre de
l'intérieur est bien agissent et c'est
un peu dommage que ce soit le maire de
calais qui rythment la sécurité du
territoire en saisissant deux ou trois
fois par jour la préfète le sous préfet
le commissaire comme ça va pas le
ministre directement
donc on attend beaucoup plus quand même
et donc je parle devant l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur qui sait de quoi
il s'agit qui est déjà intervenu a calé
un monsieur monsieur guéant est donc
aujourd'hui bon c'est vrai qu'on dit eux
le maire de kehl et courageuse mais bon
je dirais que moi je suis en mer en
responsabilité tous les élus locaux tous
les maires qui sont présents je pense le
seraient de la même façon mais ce qui
est important c'est de pas localisé
qu'elle est seulement dans son
territoire mais bien voir que quel est
le problème
final en fait du parcours des migrants
et l'impasse du parcours des migrants
qui se fait à l'international et au
niveau européen donc c'est vrai de la
même façon que quand j'entends et quand
j'entends du il ya une dizaine de jours
monsieur hollande madame merkel ouvrir
les bras en disant entrez entrez entrez
moi j'ai eu une sensation un peu de
stress pour pour peser les mots parce
que je sais très bien que ces personnes
qui vont entrer en europe vont arriver
forcément a calé et elle n'arrive pas en
bateau elle n'arrive pas en avion
il arrive en traversant le territoire
français donc on a bien un problématique
à une problématique à ce niveau là et je
voulais donc aussi vous dire que
l'attitude de ses deux et gouvernement à
de cette europe qui est vraiment une non
prise en charge du problème et donc qui
est en train de faire des choses dans
l'urgence alors qu' il y aurait mieux
valu préparer donc le dispositif bien en
amont renvoi en tous les cas à la
population française des craintes des
peurs bien évidemment puisqu'on voit
bien que les gouvernements n'arrivent
pas en fait à gouverner à gérer ce
problème et malheureusement de fait il
faut que nous ayons des discours forts
qui ne sont pas ceux du front national
il faut le dire nous n'avons pas du tout
les mêmes discours et donc nous devons
nous affirmer près fortement nous
positionner sur ce dispositif donc voilà
globalement ce que je vous vous voulez
vous portez en fait comme message en
remerciant en permanence mes collègues
qui bien évidemment me soutiennent et
pour certains qui sont en responsabilité
dans le domaine qui viennent essayer de
trouver en fait et d'apporter des
solutions
vous savez que actuellement nous avons
demandé au gouvernement de travailler
sur un contrat de territoire puisque
nous sommes dans une situation il ya une
rupture d'égalité des charges face aux
autres collectivités
nous demandons bien évidemment une
indemnisation qui n'est pas du tout dans
le dans le schéma ubuesque des 1000
euros par réfugiés qui ne veulent rien
dire et qui est vraiment qui renvoie une
image assez violente et choquant de ce
que l'on on pense en fait du placement
d'un réfugié
mais en tous les cas sachez que moi je
suis déterminé je vais jusqu'au bout de
ma démarche je suis aussi très souvent
auditionné par les parlementaires de
londres qui voilà qui ont qui sont dans
la dénégation et qui en fait refuse de
comprendre pourquoi les migrants ne
veulent pas rester en france et qu'ils
veulent absolument passer en angleterre
donc là aussi elle il ya beaucoup de
choses à faire nous voilà pour les
grandes lignes en fait de ce que nous
vivons au quotidien et je salue en même
temps bien évidemment le fair play et le
dire et le la solidarité que la
population calaisienne face à
l'événement adoptent un comportement
irréprochable parce que je peux vous
dire que ça n'est pas facile pour le
maire que je suis mais ça l'est encore
moins pour l'ensemble des riverains et
des citoyens du calaisis merci